welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and I'm Jessica Clemens and we
Jericho are breaking down Daredevil
season 1 episode 6 condemned a title
which refers both to the state of the
building Matt is holed up in this
episode and the fact that in the eyes of
the people of Hell's Kitchen he's now
guilty of various criminal activities
let's get into it we open right where we
left off after the last episode with
Matt surrounded by cops and Vladimir
Lyon on the pavement after his beat down
when Matt realizes all of these cops
work for Fisk he takes them out and
Carries an unconscious Vlad to a nearby
abandoned building meanwhile Ben Urich
is putting together an Evidence board in
the office using playing cards as
stand-ins for the main crime players in
Hell's Kitchen Vladimir and Anatoly are
represented by Jax while Fisk is
represented by the King of Diamonds this
is an obvious Nazis King Ben moniker but
could also be a nod to the diamond tip
Kane he uses in the comics Uric realizes
that the locations of the bombings were
all places that were controlled by the
Russians and he takes off and then we
get a breaking news report regarding the
explosions Oliver Hill's kitchen and the
news station is New York one the same
News Channel featured in Avengers Iron
Man 3 Spider-Man movies and even one
division episode 4. the funny thing is
New York one is a 24-hour News Network
dedicated to New York City and the real
life anchor is Annika pergament the same
woman we're seeing right here Pat
Kiernan shows up as a news anchor as
well he also appeared in Hawkeye far
from home and no way home another real
life news anchor from New York one foggy
and Karen bring Miss Cardenas to Metro
General where Claire looks after her
head wound and it's just really telling
that in the middle of all the chaos this
community comes together to help its own
despite the fact that Fisk doesn't
consider them the right kind of people
Matt calls Claire for help and patching
up Vlad and look breaking down every
fandom has created a monster in us so of
course I noticed Vladimir's rich man
belt those badishi belts average at 300
bucks should have been using that belt
like a tourniquet and now you're dying
yeah I was looking at his belt and I was
like I can't believe the prop Master
would buy this Bell he's doing it for
himself and I would too either way back
into it clear asked Matt what materials
he has to work with and this is what he
says right here half a box of nails
broken glass what uh duct tape old
roadside emergency kid a lot of plastic
shooting dude doesn't even move around
or feel anything but I guess he could
like smell glass and hear nails or
something I don't know how it works but
it's just cool Matt cauterizes vlad's
wound using a road flare which is gnarly
and Vlad screams so loud cauterizing a
wound with a flare gun is truly an
insane process not only does it allow
for more debris to go into the wound but
the bullet is left inside of him so Vlad
would most likely have died from his
injuries anyway and his screams bring a
rookie cop to the scene the guy hadn't
been on the job that long so he isn't
even in fist's Pocket yet but he yells
his location into the walkie-talkie
which brings every cop crooked and
otherwise into this building Blake and
hoppin are among the cops on the scene
and much to their Chagrin binary shows
up which puts a wrinkle in their plan to
take out anyone in the building this is
why we need reporters folks this is why
Blake refers to himself as part of the
hnt which is the hostage negotiation
team so Fisk pivots and sends all his
media contacts to the location including
whihh the in Universe MCU news station
in that we saw in Iron Man and other
films the one Christine Everhart is an
anchor for to me this is the biggest
Smoking Gun connection to the MCU folks
because that whih doesn't just roll up
anywhere it's only when like oh this is
this is Kevin feige's MCU okay that's
our jurisdiction new rockstars is doing
an in-person live show most of us have a
background an improv sketch and stand up
and we've been working behind the scenes
for a long time to develop a live new
Rockstar show and now we are super
excited to share it with the world we've
done panels at Comic Cons and live
streamed on YouTube but this is a whole
new ball game the kind of show we've
always wanted to do on May 26th in Los
Angeles myself Tommy Jessica and the new
rock stars crew are gonna escape the
blue dungeon and get on stage in front
of an in-person audience there's gonna
be special guests ridiculous comedy bits
and exclusive videos that we can never
show on YouTube it's live theater on a
multiversal level to get in-person
tickets click the link in the
description below you can't make it to
LA on May 26th it's okay you can
actually stream the worldwide digital
experience from our partners at moment
that link is also in the description
this is something we hope to be doing a
lot more of in the future so leave a
comment if you'd like us to try to come
to your city so Matt is trying to pump
Vlad for any information about this that
might help take him down but Vlad is
being less than Cooperative you think
you're different from me
from here
which you'll get there sooner or later
we all do men like us as Vlad says this
Matt's mouth Twitches turning into the
men he's fighting is what he's afraid of
and what Claire was warning him about
last episode yes while Daredevil
interrogates Vladimir Vladimir admits he
joined fist operation to get that sweet
sweet heroin and the benefit of the cops
looking the other way during their
criminal activities I'd like to remind
everyone what Daredevil said in She-Hulk
episode 8. even are two completely
different animals henchmen believe in
the cause for his goons are just there
for the paycheck Vladimir is 100 a goon
goons never make it out alive and he is
not making it out alive by the end of
this episode Vladimir asks Daredevil if
he knows Leslie Shumway when he admits
that he doesn't Vlad then critiques the
American education system which yes it
can be shoddy at times but Capone's
accountant was actually Lewis Shumway so
who's the dumb one now I just need these
small victories because we're losing in
this show right now once Daredevil wakes
up from being knocked out Vlad is out
cold on the ground this man has a bullet
in his abdomen a broken arm and now
sealing dust in and around his mouth
Daredevil listens to his heartbeat and
it's not the normal heartbeat check we
normally get whether people are telling
the truth or lying these heartbeats are
super slow he's making sure the man's
not dead yet and he is that is until
Daredevil basically breaks his rib cage
bringing him back with chest
compressions this is the first episode
Fisk and Matt speak or interact at all
you can tell when Daredevil says speak
your name in fiscos you first they are
just like twin children I can barely
make out what this says on the sniper's
bag but it's clearly an Ace of Spades
which could be a shout out to Bullseye
who we know appears in the third season
one of bullseye's signature weapons is
the Ace of Spades I don't necessarily
think this is Bullseye sniping but it
could be a nod to the villain we meet
later though this man shots are also
very much on point also what an homage
to Bullseye the man who frames Daredevil
in season three and this entire episode
is about framing Daredevil all over
again finally Daredevil admits defeat to
Claire saying she was right about the
discussion in an earlier episode
regarding being the hero or the villain
in Hell's Kitchen he finally comes to
terms with the fact that he might have
been going about it all a little too
recklessly in the song Vladimir Holmes
as he prepares for his last stand
against fisk's men is we will be raised
From the Ashes the tanks were rumbling
in the field this is right after
Daredevil does this sick ass kick to
unlock the door was it necessary no but
we closed the episode to the array of
gunfire between Vladimir and fisk's men
and now Daredevil is back on the prowl
yes yes yes yes this episode was very
slow because it's a lot of negotiating
there's not that many Easter eggs
because there's a lot of long talks on
walkie-talkies but you know what I love
doing that that's often how it feels
like just co-hosting stuff with you Jess
it's just long wonderful talks and
walkie-talkies oh and you know what
everyone watching we're gonna take a
break from these Daredevil breakdowns
because you might have heard our beloved
Jess is moving on from new rock stars to
bigger and better things you'll hear
more very very soon and just since this
might be the last video we co-host
together for a while I just wanted to
tell you how much getting to work with
you has meant to me when we started
co-hosting or want a vision after shows
in early 2021 you completely changed the
way I look at everything that we analyze
on new rock stars and I want you to know
that you brought to this channel
intelligence and insight and joy and
humor and so much honesty from
everything you did on inside Marvel to
Rogue Theory the break room the Live
Events we were able to do together in
Chicago in Austin Los Angeles your
incredible breakdown to She-Hulk all the
other videos you made for this Channel
all the way back to being able to work
with you and your hilarious Randy Newman
sketch on our sketch team you have been
a true professional a delight to work
with and we just haven't told you that
enough and you've had to put up with so
much and you did it all with
class and I knew that we wouldn't have
you forever because you are a rock star
and I love you and please please come
back anytime and I can't wait for you to
show this whole world what you can
really do oh I hate this I'm so bad at
goodbyes it does feel so Bittersweet but
I will be I will guess as much as I can
please do it does feel bittersweet for
us because we started a lot of the stuff
together at least for me one division
was like my biggest thing it's gonna be
sad and this is my last video but I'm so
happy with what we've done and what you
guys can just go back and watch of me oh
to finish the video so no one let's
break this up okay so everybody please
please support this growing Network here
at new rock stars by grabbing something
from our nurse store merch store nerd
right Dodge shop by the time you're
watching this you may already know where
uh Jessica is moving on to so support
her wherever she goes and show her the
love that she deserves from the hard
work she's put in here at new rock stars
and at college humor and everything that
she's done you're gonna be amazed by
what she accomplishes
um but also please subscribe to the
three channels on the new rock stars
Network follow Jessica Lulu underscore
Clemons and uh we'll see everyone the
next time bye
oh no oh no oh no
[Music]